au québec
active doit bientôt un an la comparaison
aux autres ça donne vraiment la joie de
notre vie alors moi vous savez j'ai 15
ans quand moi je me compare aux autres
ce que volée mal à jouer dans ma vie
c'était l'utilisation ensuite c'est
collectivisation au sommet pour moi
l'intimidation c'était quand je le
faisais si on avait des groupes d'amis
autour de nous on attend mieux peut-être
nos amis puis ose même pas intervenir
parce que pourquoi parce qu'un
intervenir quand quelqu'un saurait
excéder c'est pas cool immédiatement
devient de tanguy et de l'intimidation
moi aussi moi je me rappelle j'arrivais
toujours la première place à dans les
lignes j'étais toujours vite à l'école
chez le psy ce qui te courir je pense
qu'il faudra même mais j'aimerai
toujours ma famille mais je me faisais
push et puis je me faisais frapper à
l'arrière puis avait personne qui vient
c'est un aperçu à neutre alors quand
j'ai su que c'était pour la maladie
coeliaque qu'à cocher sur jalle pas
vraiment changé quand je ressentais rien
probablement entre vous qui a poussé
quoi la maladie coeliaque la maladie des
petits de maladie qui fait que tu
confonds demandé j'ai mangé le gluten on
enlève le thème c'est comme tu ligue à
tours les pentes moi je mange par une
bombe sur les bombes fait que je m'avoue
resterait pas grand chose à marc johnson
cours et puis je mange mes frites mais
moi ça l'a fait avec moi la façon que ça
m'affecter alors de plus en plus de la
huitaine que je mangeais c'est le plus
de moins en moins grand public que je
grandissais alors quand on a su que
c'était la maladie coeliaque je n'avais
pas changé comment je me sentais alors
quand j'ai rejoint rencontre un homme
tony haurat benz gang et quant à notre
vie change dans les moments les instants
et pendant les longues périodes de temps
je me suis rendu compte que notre vie le
change pendant 6 mois ou un mot en
jambes comme tout le monde je pense à ma
vie allait changer de 2004 à 2005
ça marche pas demain pour moi la
première maman qui a changé ma vie
c'était le 19 décembre
je me rends pêche joue aux cartes et
puis tu te couches sont là 7
ce que j'ai vu dans le cloud en noir et
je suis de trouver là de la lumière à la
fin du cours
je ne trouvais pas alors dans ce couloir
noir là je me sentais son jeu changer de
chaîne et puis juste j'avais plus quoi
faire je regarde à noël je dis petit je
regardais ma fuite je te pète jetaient
alors j'avais déjà très injuste et
publicité pour la vie alors acheté point
la jci papa je dois je me réveille le
lendemain matin sur les taux grecs mais
ça c'est commencer à se reproduire de
plus en plus en plus puisque j'ai envie
qu'un je maniais pâte aperçu que le
joueur ait pu vivre puisque quand mon
père est descendu l'escalier et puis je
suis dit maintenant ou jamais quand je
dis maintenant j'ai mais je veux dire ce
que je prends le courage je gagnais mon
paquet 70,8 vive puisque déjà 13,1 je
vais plus d ambition ou jamais et puis à
un point je vais prendre ma vie je
donnais la peine à mes parents et mes
amis
quand j'ai pris le courage je me sais
qu'il faut que je parle lui par un roman
par descendre les escaliers je me suis
dis pas parce que je peux te parler la
première chose que je faisais mon père
papa 100pts en plus de vivre
alors pendant une heure de 9 heures et
29 je m'appelle très spécifiquement de
la minute jusqu'à 10h30 j parlement pas
quand je sentais les émotions et
inondations la comparaison aux autres et
que moi je me sentir et puis moi je
fasse de mon père à l'oeil pétille
quelqu'un
maintenant il restait confiant alors ça
fait vraiment pas son histoire que les
jeunes at il dit à chaque jour de
l'école puis elles vont un arbre
et puis c'est ta ble et des larmes qui
parle est évident j'ai bien aujourd'hui
me fait il dit qu'il ya gratuit l'armée
morts alors cette nuit je mens pas
arrêté sept personnes pour moi la
personne qui m'a guidé la lumière qui
était intéressant dans ce couloir noir
alors à ce point là je me suis que
demain je me réveillais je trouve mes
balles en jeu développé la confiance je
développe et du leadership
mais comme vous savez que dans la façon
que je prends maintenant cela peut finir
il va encore un autre maman qui se
préparait pour moi alors dans le moine
mais jamais développer la confiance que
j'avais du leadership je vais je
connaissais mes valeurs mais je m'avance
l'anglais dans une direction qui était
pas trop bonne alors je me suis battu
avec quelqu'un mon école et puis j'ai eu
un malentendu avec quelques chats bus
quand on parle et on parlait beaucoup de
potes
et puis ils ont appelé l'école et on dit
je pense que vous étiez en vaut prendre
époque j'étais pauvre est alors amené
tous
cette paille cette frustration là j'ai
eu une conversation avec mon directeur
d'école qui m'a dit alex dutilh du chip
et il utilise pas de la bonne façon en
soit il fallait que je croyais en moi et
que je cherche
voyez comment que je changeais mois
excuse quand j'ai développé mon
leadership dans cet été là j'ai pris du
temps j'ai pris de sanction pour
développer ma confiance
mon leadership mes valeurs positives
parce que sinon changer notre vie mais
quand on veut qu'on la bonne direction
au moins comme une confiance faux sang
avant de nous que oui je change ma vie
oui je pense plus suicide mais quand
même on s'avance dans une direction on
est pauvre m'assure alors en sorte j'ai
trouvé je vous remercie de cette
situation que je les plus vives mais
j'avais pas vraiment toujours des
ambitions
acheter un peu une autre alors ce que
j'ai fait du bashing confiance fausse en
avant de moi alors comme vous à vous le
savez cet éloge y travailler sur moi il
travaille comme je fais me partir et
puis finalement le 1er octobre
je déambule fait d'erreur et puis
finalement je me suis peut-être rendu
compte que mon histoire avec la valeur
puis à peut-on être sûr ceux qui
écouterait mon histoire je n'ai pas
positif pour la première fois de ma vie
je pensais que peut-être je pourrais
faire quelque chose demain alors quand
je t'avais maison j papa j'ai vraiment
de mots et d'une fin des conférences ted
fin des vidéos parce qu'il y avait là la
nouvelle afin de la business en ligne
puis moi j'étais vraiment intéressé avec
ça et puis seulement que j'ai découvert
que peut-être je les valeurs que
peut-être je pourrais avoir un impact
alors je me suis jeune histoire jdd
stratégie j'ai appris des affaires bien
une les premières fois que j'ai appris
c'est que le succès des autres salles
animaux par an si vous comparez à
quelqu'un d'autre alors je prends
l'exemple de moi à l'école avec
quelqu'un que je me compare à
mathématiques 6-10 ans lui capable
d'avoir 90 % et moi je me crois pas
négativement cette personne ne sait ce
que tu veux pas qu à penser que des
capable alors en sorte qu'on pense que
focus sorti résultats qu'est-ce que tout
est capable fixer des objectifs et des
ambitions
parce que tant que tu compares quelqu'un
d'autre si ce que très peu quand même
l'approché de caisse que eux sont
capables alors 1990 deux côtés focus sur
toi prends tes et tape ma main et on va
marcher vers son objectif
puis faites à mon année du somr que
cette personne
mais ce sera juste parce que c'était à
votre avis sur ton élu chez +4 travaillé
sur l'histoire que sur les autres la
deuxième chose que je m'en allais a
perçu c'est que mes amitiés sont
détériorées alors le plus en plus cons
ce qu'on parle c'est le plus influent
que non on va perdre des amis
alors moi je me faisais trendy et je me
comparé aux autres puis la façon pour
mettre une barrière fauche de confiance
avant moi c'est toujours vouloir
l'attention des gens alors ça ça
l'énervé beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
à mon école il s'y arrête à l'intérieur
tu es tellement nerveux en suisse se
doit par sorte qu'est au jeu suivant je
parlais beaucoup puis je me fais que
quand on se compare aux autres on va
perdre des amis parce que ils vont
trouver s'énerve 1 et puis ça va ce sera
un point que enceinte il y est la
dernière chose que j'ai appris c'est que
si deux premiers les affaires show là
que je vais vous expliquer ça l'est sera
un point ok nous penser deviennent
dangereux je suis négatif alors on
revenait au premier tome mais je pense
que finalement je pourrais avoir un
impact qui a finalement sur ce qui
coûterait mon histoire mes stratégies
mon vécu
j'en ai un impact positif puisque je
préfère une contribution une
contribution à l'humanité faire des
conférences
merci
[Applaudissements]